sur les décombres de ce qui fut une
maison il ya encore quelques mois une
équipe de volontaires s'activent en
plein soleil en mars des roquettes
russes ont détruit si le foyer de six
personnes qui par chance on tue le temps
de trouver refuge dans cette cave bp a
tout gamer réparons l'ensemble une ong
basée à qu'yves nettoie les dégâts
causés par l'armée russe
nous avons aidé 15 fameux nettoyées
quatre villages et ici à locatif ce cas
nous avons prévu de reconstruire 12
maisons avant l'arrivée de l'hiver
une idée qui a pris racine dans des
rêves organisé par ses fans de techno
déblayer et reconstruire tout en dansant
en somme joindre l'utile à l'agréable de
manière bénévole
est
partout à luca chiffres qu'à ces jeunes
sont accueillis à bras ouverts sans leur
aide il aurait été impossible pour
oleksy de reconstruire sa maison
je manque de mots pour leur dire à quel
point je leur suis redevable
je les remercie du fond du coeur je suis
très reconnaissant merci à dieu d'avoir
donné à l'ukraine des jeunes comme ça
mais mime notre contribution c'est que
ma femme leur fais à manger conseils
je suis tellement inquiète à 65 ans j'ai
perdu mon logement
est-ce que j'ai vraiment besoin de ça
maintenant
les russes sont venus ici des gants
détruit ma maison
est-ce que c'est poutine qui valent à
reconstruire un pays dont on a des
charges à payer à notre vieille voisine
car on vit chez elle on a des factures
pour tous c'est
la guerre contre la russie a poussé la
société ukrainienne à s'entraider comme
jamais auparavant il ya évidemment
celles et ceux qui sont au front pour
tenter de défendre leur pays et puis
ceux qui comme ces jeunes tentent déjà
de le reconstruire